the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social media I want to say thank you
guys for supporting the special uh
YouTube did what YouTube does to me all
the time and they pulled it out of the
algorithm they limited the ad so
killing the views on it but you know
what it's still kicking ass so thank you
you gotta know about it you got to go
see it if you haven't watch it share it
with some people that's how that [__]
gets around and gets helped out
um and if you gotta have more then you
gotta check out the patreon here listen
it's the Honeydew with y'all and I do
this show with y'all and you all have
the wildest stories we just talked to a
guy who needed a double lung transplant
gets it because somebody who knows
somebody who knows somebody in his
circles kid is dying and they have are a
100 match then marries the donor's
girlfriend they're about to have a baby
it's five dollars y'all no other tears
or none of that [__] honeydew with y'all
go sign up you get a month free if you
sign up for a year and you get the
Honeydew a day early you're getting an
ad free you're getting no additional
cost and if you're looking for
a new podcast to listen to then listen
to my old podcast the crab feast and
today's guest actually has a kick-ass
episode of The Crab Feast uh so go check
that out and uh June 23rd and 24th I'm
in Tacoma Washington July 7th and 8th
Appleton Wisconsin all right there it is
now you guys know we're doing over here
we highlight the low lights I like to
say these are the stories behind the
storytellers
and technically I'm very excited to have
this guest back on the Honeydew ladies
and gentlemen Eddie Letterman welcome
back I'm still thinking about how little
those guys that guy's lungs are he's got
little kid lungs in there no but he got
he's got baby boy do you know
first of all it's great to have you I
think I have elderly
the odds of anyone being 100 match and
he gets to get it without getting in
line too because it's a direct owner
yeah and and then he the family wants to
get to know him they fall in love so he
starts hanging around them and the last
person he wants to meet is the
girlfriend he's like she's and they all
his friends oh he's the girlfriend of
the guy yeah that was a kid I was like
why are you no no so he's he's hanging
around this family and he's very
uncomfortable because he's like I have
your son's lungs right you know like
this guilty I feel like I should but
also I'm wildly uncomfortable and
um the girlfriend but they're all
telling him you're just like him you
look dumb you look like them you act
like them and then the girlfriend falls
in love with them he took her breath
away and
well done and the donors the donors
parents don't care for her anymore after
that they feel like it's a betrayal but
they're married now and expecting a kid
five dollars patreon honey do with y'all
uh why don't you plug and promote
everything Annie Letterman real quick
before we get into it I have uh this
upcoming weekend maybe I don't know
dates or times but uh the first weekend
in June I will be at magoobies in
Baltimore or your hometown we share a
white trash accent I'm from Philadelphia
um I'm gonna be in
um
Salt Lake City in June I'm gonna be in
with Josh Potter I'm gonna be in San
Antonio in June and then I'm gonna be in
Philadelphia in August go to
annieleterman.com shows I have a podcast
called trash Tuesday and I have a
podcast I really like that's my own
podcast that's all my from my heart with
my boyfriend and a bunch of really cool
guests called Annie wood they're both on
YouTube check them out
all right so I said officially back yeah
well I did here's the thing the things
that happened to me
in my life are pretty traumatizing and
so it depends on where I'm at in my life
when I tell the stories and I think
sometimes it's important for me to not
tell the stories that's like a big step
in my recovery and stuff with having
like some PTSD and stuff with it to not
say the stories always and when I did
when I did do this podcast last time I
just was in kind of a little bit of a a
triggered State and I didn't want to
like
it's just a lot of times when I tell
this story My People kind of go like
what about your parents where were your
parents all this stuff I'm really good
with my parents I have full like love
and forgiveness and a really good
relationship with them so that was kind
of what I was feeling I was like I don't
want to put my parents through this
again you know their friends listen to
things I do they meet people they find
out I'm a comedian and so that's kind of
what I was feeling are they getting did
they get some of that what have they had
backlash it's not like I don't think
they get like personal backlash it's
more just like probably
just my own like there's no neighbors
taking out the trash like why the [__]
why are you in high school where were
you when she was in high school they're
not doing that seeing them at the
Wawa's parents it's it's more I think
just like wanting to
like move on from the stories and not
keep like pulling the Band-Aid off of
them too too soon but with that said
I've done a lot of work on myself and
it's not really that much of a thing but
sometimes you know like I'm sure you
know
sometimes when you tell these stories
you get an influx of people telling you
their stories and then you're like oh my
God your DMs are just filled with like
stories and you're like
okay and I still like when people share
their stories but it's always like a you
know two sides that's what this show is
I mean our our inbox is full of dark
stuff my meet and greets and like I'm
like people start talking to me and I go
they'll be like my uncle and I'm like
okay
um cash your card first and then we'll
get to it baby
uh let's do the transaction so I don't
have to do this well okay it starts with
my uncle you're like oh my own but um
but I love when people share their
stories with me too it's like you know
it's it's uh it's also I like being open
I like the people I'm also here I've
always been it's for me it's always been
about the comedian or the guest like
whatever they want like some people you
didn't want the episode to go out so
they were like do you want to save it I
was like no yeah just delete it for God
forbid anything goes out and even if
it's a mistake because we know
are they ever a mistake are they the
funniest thing that's ever happened the
thing the truth is if you had released
that episode and like if I it would have
been fine
you know I work I work a lot of my
anxiety but I have like that like
spinniness where it's like oh and I've
had this like I have I've had um people
on my solo podcast girls will come on
and go oh is that your side and I go
yeah and they go oh that's I have the
same like good side and I go oh okay
well do you wanna I'll just sit on that
I'll you could we can have my bad side
my bad side's still cute
um but I'm like well you can switch
sides or whatever and they go oh no it's
like it's fine I'm like okay and then
come the clip they're like take it down
I don't want to post it that happens to
me multiple times it's like and I
understand that I don't get mad at
people because it's like I understand
you thinking you're good in the moment
and then there's just something that
like triggers you on that day where
you're like you know you feel my glass
used to call it podcast hangover yes you
wake up the next day what did I say what
did I do yeah yeah and I think like it's
okay you know I haven't done anything
I'm never gonna tell a story that's
gonna incriminate me
like I I I'm I'm good on my end I feel
good about myself and stuff but I think
that I've done a lot of work and just
with like PTSD it's like
um well talk to us about that what you
don't have to talk to be specific about
it but
PTSD like what sort of work are you
doing are you in therapy I do ketamine
treatment sponsored on anniewood what's
up mind Bloom right here on the honey
can you [__] believe it I did it did
you do it oh yeah it's amazing listen
I'm so anti-all that stuff so I was like
you know what I did the six sessions I
[__] it's amazing it was amazing it's
amazing it was like a literal like you
know when we all used to drink or do
drugs we're grabbing [__] about a
handful in the gal this seemed to be a
perfectly prescribed it was right about
58 minutes for me because the last two
minutes I find myself going all right
I'm good all right I'm back I'm back I'm
back but man I'm how many milligrams did
you get I don't remember did you lie so
you get the most I didn't think I got
the most second yeah are you kidding me
I'm like no what 15 years old
raver me is like are you serious I can
sponsored this is like the craziest I'm
like
Annie shut up
I was like what do you she's like um
what are your interests like so I can
get you ads you like I'm like um like
hair extensions Academy and like still
waiting on the hair extensions
um but it's like it really is amazing
but that helps I've done a lot of
Ayahuasca I do a lot of like plant
medicines
um stuff like that I do breath work
um do you don't smoke cannabis do you I
cannot that is so that's a lot of money
and by the way not only is it not a
medicine for me it's not a medicine when
I'm hanging out with you it's the
opposite to poison I would wake up I
would be like first of all no voice like
like our job is to talk you know and I
will be looking at camera and if you
have a problem with that I want you to
visit why you have a problem with that
why don't you want to be included in the
conversation I'm sorry I include the
audience okay so I will be looking at
you guys
because you're here with us okay so just
be a part of the team and grow up
um anyway so
I will wake up this is my voice this is
my job this is my instrument after
hanging out with you at The Comedy Store
can't talk can't breathe I'm like I
could have may as well have woken up in
the Sahara reaching like the only Waters
of Mirage like I'm just like
just cake chalky throat can't think
can't think head in a cloud just so
[__] up that's you
you do that I think it's the plant it's
you I think it's the amount that's being
rolled and passed and we do have good
conversations so then I don't want to
leave always I was your gossiping the
other night I heard about it secondhand
from my boyfriend I was like what did I
miss this is [__] [__] and then
you didn't respond to my voice memo and
then I saw you and I go when are we
gonna talk about this and here we are we
can't um but we can't talk about that
I know I have certain people that I'm
like I can't even have you on my podcast
because we would just bleep the entire
thing but I um but
yeah I do that
um just a lot of stuff just and I've
been really working on my anxiety and I
watch all day I watch Like Joe dispenza
videos I watch Esther Hicks videos I
watch like anything about subconscious
reprogramming anything about moving your
thoughts to positive thinking I do a lot
of work in the morning I wake up and if
I have negative spinning thoughts I just
I try to zap them out of the way right
away gratitude I will just do anything
to fight for my freedom and my happiness
and my peace yeah because I'm just not
interested in being fighting all the
time I think that I had all these things
happen when I was little and I took them
on as like a part of it that's what I
wanted to ask you specifically is this a
sort of um and again we do we're not
going to get specific we can get
specific a stacking of things or
you know sometimes it's just one
incident for people
um so this was a series of incidents
that occurred over well this was I had
like when you go to do your work on what
are you working on what am I working on
I'm working on how things are
manifesting for me in the present moment
good what are my like what are my
ruminating thoughts what do I keep
coming back on but I I got over I was
assaulted by my teacher in high school
which was like my big
event of my life that was really and how
old were you I was 15. and then and my
teacher was like this white dreaded guy
I went to this like school that is like
the fact it's still running is crazy
well my parents made some sort of like
plea bargain deal I don't know what
happened but it didn't there there
wasn't in my my position justice so I'm
always kind of fighting between wanting
to like Chris Hanson this [__] and then
also just like move on so I always just
kind of go back and forth like
you know about it but what I realized
was when I was like I used to tell
people this story like I wasn't like in
the brownies I wasn't a Girl Scout or
anything but it was almost like my
traumatic experiences were like these
patches that I had like Acquired and I
felt like people needed to know the
things that had happened to me to like
understand who I was and and these
things that I had gone through and I
think because I did end up taking my
teacher to court and you did yeah and
there was really very little support
that's really when it got worse it was
like being called a liar being right my
um my dork handle would be loogies on
when I go to my car it was like crazy it
was insane wow so the students also the
students the teachers were not
supporting me I get emails from them
every once in a while my teachers will
be like oh I I wish I had been there for
you and it's like it's just move on
like why because it came out later that
he actually well there's so many that
keep coming out right so it's not just
him no it's not just it's not just the
teacher it's the school it was a lot of
and maybe it's all I don't know if it's
all schools I only went to the school so
but it's like more keep coming out like
I had this one disciplinarian who was
like I would look back and I go you know
I'd actually like that guy because he
was the only one that had boundaries in
this high school because it was a school
for juvenile delinquents and I think
that that's where you went and I think
that kids that
that are like On The Fringe or looked at
as like not trustworthy are the ones
that are the biggest targets because
they're like No One's Gonna believe
these kids you know and I think do you
mind pausing for a second why are we in
a juvenile delinquent school can we just
jump back a little bit all right this is
where my parents come in all right then
we don't have to talk about it I just
they just sent me to it it's so weird I
wasn't kicked out of you who stole a car
I didn't start really stealing cars
until I went to the school until I was
surrounded by Young criminals
program exactly the school had a good
art program and
um
where they thought it did and turns out
the art teacher likes to Jackson Pollock
the students the back of the students
knees with only white paint
um but you have to laugh if you don't
laugh it's weird but um okay I'm scared
no don't be scared it's fine but um but
yeah it's it uh was like a weird school
it was an alternative school so a lot of
kids were kicked out or was kids with
like learning disabilities and I was
like starting to like smoke cigarettes
and stuff but I wasn't like really that
bad okay so you're not getting arrested
I was like sneaking out like there I was
doing some stuff yeah I did that but but
I think keeping me around well-behaved
kids would have been the right move
rather than like sending me to
Worst Behavior people that are [__]
lit their schools on fire and [__]
they're people that had just done crazy
things I mean I was like having to call
People's parents like your daughter's on
heroin like when I was like 14 you know
it was just a lot it was a lot of
of uh intense stuff going on in there I
always said were you there for a few
years
um I was there well I started there they
let me skip eighth grade too so I was
like this place is so cool but it's
there was no education I learned nothing
it was more of like warehousing us there
were pillows instead of chairs
is that fun just pillows on the ground
no chairs pillows on the ground I mean
some of this rooms had chairs but a lot
of the rooms just had pillows and you
would lay on them we had a class called
movie class nah yeah and guess what we
did in that just watch movies
after lunch you come home smoking opium
a lunch come on come back to school we
were smoking opinion opium I know where
you got it because we had it everybody
everybody would get it at the Grateful
Dead shows they would all go to the
parking lots and buy the Opium and then
would come back and filter and I'm like
where the [__] we would go to Luzerne
Ave in Philly and we would there was
just like streets you could go to we
would get wet
is that the PCP I think it's PCP I don't
know it was just called wet and I smell
I just wouldn't smoke anything I think
that's weed dipped him I would I think
that's what it tasted weird there was a
squeakage there was a squeaky vibe
yeah you had to open drug markets and
yeah drug markets so we were just doing
whatever and um
but the school you go back to school
like that they didn't care but I mean
you could actually function there was a
day there was a day there was a guy
named
um which I call him I'll just call him
Luke he's actually
I want to say Leo's because it's like so
funny how success what he got successful
in oh so our school had a glass blowing
Studio
and he would always he was very talented
at glassblowing and he's he but he made
bongs and now he's like one of the
biggest bong oh is that one of the only
bomb companies he's like world-class
boss
it's like the it's like I'm a comedian
he's a bong seller I have like one
friend who's like uh he's a professor
and and all this stuff but it's like and
then the rest of everyone's like in jail
prison or in jail dead or working at
like a Verizon kiosk you know you're
like yeah
[__]
it's really I mean it's a it was an
interesting thing and it was weird being
a juvenile delinquent too because I was
like
like who do I look up to like mobster
like who am I looking up to people that
die and shoot people like it was weird
you don't have any Heroes really when
you're juvenile delinquent who am I
looking up to people that get like
visited in prison
um but you go home at night right it's
not us oh yeah no I go home at night but
anyway so these so this guy that became
a bong Lord a bong King he
um
here and this guy Brian picked me up for
school one day
because I lived in my neighborhood and
they picked me up and they like we go to
this place we used to go to this place
Rex Avenue near the school
it was a dead end and then it was just
like open like Philadelphia Pennsylvania
Park like beautiful like woods and stuff
but we would drive down to a dead end to
smoke weed it's like that's what we're
dealing with with the brain cells of us
juvenile delinquent ding dong kids into
a place where we could just be boxed in
at any time from the window Sirens
siren the universe was like yes that was
bad
so we got out of Rex Avenue on this dead
end and they like hot box the car and I
just am higher than I've ever been I'm
like guys and this isn't just weed this
is the [__] no this is weird this is
weird but it's a level of weed that I'm
not I'm 14 years old I've been smoking
weed for like a year and a half you know
like I'm like I am so [__] up I'm like
I cannot go to school and they think
it's so funny but I'm like I'm literally
unable I can't do it
and they drive me in anyway laughing at
me open the doors up I'm sure the smoke
Bellows out I'm like how am I gonna pull
this off because if you get caught
caught you get in trouble but it's like
they will let you
[Music]
ah they are trying to tell you so so
they'll let you what like they'll let
like if you're gonna say something but
you can't get out like selling weed you
can't get caught like with a joint like
they were loose you know
but
I was like I think this I'm too [__]
up to even like I wasn't able to like
talk
we walk in they go
surprise it's movie day we just had a
day off from school board that we were
just watching movies all day for no
reason the whole day the whole day the
whole school was just watching and the
school was small I had 17 kids in my
graduating class it was Tiny class yeah
the whole class the whole not just great
yeah holy [__] so I went there and then
I skipped up they let me after I took my
teacher to court all of a sudden they
were like you can do two grades in one
did you know you can graduate in a few
months is that really they let you
[__] just get the [__] out of there
did they but there was a disciplinarian
so okay go ahead there was a
disciplinarian who was like our math
teacher or science teacher one of those
things and he was an [__] he was the
only one that was like yelling at us and
making us do stuff and As I Grew Older I
started to look at him and go you know
what I actually really liked that guy
this is the guy you said you know he
really like had boundaries and we talked
called them all by their first name
which was like don't send your kids to
school where they call like
it's so you don't [__] each other like
it's mister and you know Miss is like
but anyway so um
so he
um yeah so I was like oh he was he was
good you know and then I get tagged on
Facebook from some of my old
uh classmates and they go another
teacher and it's an article about how
they caught him with Kitty porn him
Kitty porn so the reason he wasn't
trying to [__] us the reason he wasn't
trying to focus was too old we were too
old and I appreciate him he actually was
the best teacher at the school because
he at least wasn't that [__] great is
that amazing so then okay so there was a
teacher who got caught with it he turned
all the girls Annie forever the girls in
my grade seventh grade they would all
say Ryan he looks down our shirts he
stands over us and looks down our shirt
our boobs more and you know we're
seventh grade boys like nah you don't
even have boobs every year
little smaller sisters of like if you
and I went to high school together and
your little sister now has them they
would say it and they would and boom
[__] turns his [__] computer
lap School given laptop in forgets to
take the kitty porn off and boom he gets
busted after all these [__] years
those girls were 100 it's so nasty it's
so weird I know you do get a Vibe you're
like is this weird I used to have one of
my teachers would um she'd be like you
need to wear like less suggestive
clothing I was it was like backless
shirts were in then
she's like the male teachers are like
having trouble that I'm like I don't
really see how that's my problem first
of all I'm a minor and if the male
teachers are even openly discussing it
with anybody why are you coming up to me
like I did something [__] like go [__]
yourself my husband's [__] someone
that wears shirts like you it's it's so
nasty but so anyway so so I find out
about about
the kitty porn then this other guy hits
me up this classmate and he goes oh I
found out that
um
the teacher that so when the teacher had
assaulted me
um there were two art teachers uh the
one that assaulted me and then this
other one who I had always really like
liked he had always been like someone I
could go to so when this happened when
my teacher jerked off on me I went to
the other art teacher and I told him and
he had been his student
oh he had been a student he had been his
student and then became his teacher
and I told him and he said well I'm torn
because part of me feels like a father
and I want to go like kick his ass and
the other part of me wasn't there so I
don't know what happened
Jesus and I'm like okay so then he makes
me go to my my uh was anyone there for
you
[Music]
um
was there my guy friends were kind of
like one of them was there a female
teacher anymore not really no I went to
my female teacher and she just was like
because we all what happened was so the
teacher that assaulted me and his wife
were like these like white people with
dreads yeah and she was my English
teacher so they would get us over they
groomed us they'd be like come over she
was like tutoring me they'd got us
alcohol and weed they would get us like
parrots Bay like coconut rum like kid
drink [__] and um
and they'd be tutoring me and then they
convinced my parents this is where it
gets like weird with my parents but it's
like here's what I realized with my
parents they my mom and it all comes
full circle because my mom has revealed
more information from her childhood to
me where it goes like Oh okay she didn't
have the same experience she had the
opposite experience so in her head
the other things will happen but I'll
get to that in a second so so
um
so they were having me over
and some of my friends over
to like work on stuff they convinced my
parents that we should be able to sleep
over and my friend's parents that we
should go to sleep over we're gonna be
going to college soon it's healthy for
us to like start having some distance
and you know we're working late we're
writing these papers later I've never
had to write a paper at the school you
know what I mean they're like ding ding
ding here's your paper
I mean I was putting like clip art in my
papers my papers were like pictures I
was like here it's like hieroglyphics
like not real school so
um so my parents agree to this my
friends and parents agree to this they
had like a room my parents like were
like oh we have this extra futon they
like made a room for us in their house
okay and everyone's just sort of like
young kids you and one more it was me
and this and and my best friend at the
time and then other kids would come hang
out and then it started being like Oh
let's get naked and like oh let's go
back together
I you know I honestly don't know how
long I was there for I think it was like
a couple of months senior year oh just a
couple well I was 15 turning 16 or maybe
I just turned 16. it was like I
graduated when I was 16.
from there so it was like that
year so you're a kid yeah and they're
getting naked with you yeah and and then
he's my only naked dude because he's got
a wife so there's other boys there
they're naked
and then and they are they also from
your school yeah they are
and so then it's like
yeah it's like hard to remember because
I haven't told this in a while
I don't feel traumatized telling this
though we'll see tomorrow no you don't
have to edit it I said baths your baths
and stuff and so I was there any way to
get you naked after a little while right
and just like weird and like oh wouldn't
it be funny if we're all naked and then
so then his wife went out of town for
something and my friend like wasn't
allowed to come over for some reason so
it was just me and him one night and I
woke up and he was watching me sleep
and I was like so creepy I was like oh
creepy even though like all this stuff
was like but you're like in it they're
like is this weird you're like even
though obviously it seems weird now I
was like you're just like a kid like
is this what people do I don't know it
was very weird I didn't like want to be
naked I wasn't like a comfortable kid
like that I wasn't like a naked kid you
know always watching you sleep naked
well I wasn't naked I don't think when I
was sleeping but I mean they were all we
were all naked it was weird so anyway so
then uh I wake up to him watching me
sleep and I was like so weird oh get out
of here so then he leaves and then in
the morning his wife calls I pick up I'm
like I'm like yeah he was watching me
sleep it's so weird
like just
like outing it like that what a weird
thing and then she's like can I talk to
him for a second so then they have a
talk about whatever and then he comes
over and he's like I really want to like
I want to draw you it's like I have all
these like bodies around me and am I
drawing them he's like can I draw you
nude and I remember thinking like oh my
friend would do it you know I was like I
really was not wanting to do it you know
but I left my socks on and I remember
thinking like that was my bartering I
was like okay well then
that'll be
like I'm not really a naked or whatever
doing this at the school or this is at
his house
and then he and I have to go to work I
worked at Color Me Mine like the pottery
yeah I remember calling
so I had to go to work there soon I had
like my little khakis or whatever my
uniform was and I um and he was like let
me draw you nude and I just like peer
pressured myself and I was like okay I
was like you've been doing it's like
would be too crazy so then I'm like
laying on my stomach and he's like it's
better if I'm naked too he gets naked
sits on the back of my legs and jerks
off on me no and I'm like completely
like
like in shock can't talk like Frozen
can't believe it's happening I get up I
go to the bathroom I just pull I don't
even wipe his jizz off I just pull my
pants on I'm so freaked out like I just
pull my pants and I go to work and then
I'm talking to my said nothing you just
decided I just got up and left and then
you said nothing
I don't think so I don't think you said
anything I mean who knows he might have
just been like have a good day at work I
mean I
I was a long time ago so but anyway so
so then I go to
Color Me Mine and my manager I'm like
I'm like a weird thing
happened and I told him he was like oh
that guy's a child molester
and I was like yeah it doesn't feel like
good what happened so then I called my
best friend and I tell her and she's
like oh he's done stuff like that to me
before don't worry about it he's just
getting cheeky with you and I'm like
that's not [__] on your cheeks does
not mean cheeky I think I have a better
idea of the English language but um yeah
so
so then I was like okay and she was like
don't worry about it and so then I was
kind of like she's out like in my head
I'm like this no longer is my friend I'm
not dealing with this [__] anymore
because I was like realizing like in the
moment in real time like how bad what
just happened was and how bad all this
stuff leading up to it had been but I
was like like um manipulate him as just
like a kid it's weird it's your
authority figures it's like all this
stuff
so
so then I'm like okay so then I start
kind of like
Gathering my evidence like I start
hitting up other girls that have been
around people I've seen him with I'm
like all right so I find five girls he's
done stuff too and one will testify with
me and the one that will testify with me
is
like a liar she's not lying I was there
I know she's not lying but but she's a
liar you know so I'm like [__] all right
well whatever so I mean I shouldn't call
her a liar but she had been she was a
little she was she was a cutter she was
a lot of things you know and so um
um
precious angel I'm sure doing great now
I'm sorry if you're listening but um it
was just like kind of like oh you know
but there was like a there was a girl
who had turned 18 while she was there he
was dating her
okay that was like having a full affair
with her yeah she was still a senior
there was
um a girl who his wife
was it was a student there but was also
her mom was his wife's therapist
he had
kissed her had had made out with her
with his mother-in-law no with the
daughter with the girl daughter and she
was like my age and and you know was
like oh massages and then like he was
tutoring her with art and then making
out with her kissing her and stuff they
didn't want to do it the mother was like
no I feel like I'm helping the fan like
it was a lot of
people that are
sick yeah and their goal is not to help
her protect children it's to protect
the comfort and not having to go to
court I I don't know what it was but
also having gone through the court
system and how difficult that was and
painful that was like I don't want to
like shame people that that don't speak
out to I used to be very Vigilant about
that and really pissed when when I would
hear stories where women didn't go to
the cops but then I'm like you know what
whatever is gonna like help your piece
and stuff like even though I did feel an
obligation when I got gotten to make
sure that no one else got and I was like
I'm done he [__] me up like and I
really felt that way I was like I got
ruined like why did you think ruined why
I was I just felt like I got damaged I'm
done it's like it's not gonna be okay
you know you really did but I didn't but
now that's like the work I've done where
it's like that's the thing that that
happened to me as a kid that's not nice
I think someone did too exactly and it's
not mine it's not like
it's not mine to keep and I had to
really that was like a big lesson for me
where I had to realize like when I was
using it as these like Badges and I
needed people to understand what I'd
been through like
it was it I was just dragging this like
dreaded guy through every like yep by
the dreads in every part of my life I
thought about him every day for
like 15 20 years is this
and I don't think about this at all and
I can tell you this like yes I can get
emotional be vulnerable but I'm not like
attached to it the way I was before it
really is like
it is just
it's like a moment in time
and I learned a lot and I'm really proud
of myself for how I acted there and I
really like I I
you know I didn't have a lot of support
but I was able to like support myself
and I feel very support I kind of did
you know I did you know I did but what I
learned from that experience to [__]
if my daughter came home and told me
what you just [__] told I want to go
for is this guy alive yeah still alive
he is he's a successful artist in
Philadelphia
with his ex-wife now they got divorced
uh at like a couple years after one that
helped him this lady yeah they got naked
with us yeah you crossed the kids with
her where but it was like a couple years
later and it was like and we both like
and like ran the other direction no but
um but I looked up I found her on uh
Facebook and she's following some weird
Guru she's just one of those people that
has to have someone
telling her what to do or whatever uh my
Orioles are finally good this year
really good and I thought I was you know
what I'm gonna take my daughter to see
her first baseball game and I wanted to
go get good seats just the two of us we
can go walk around the park like she's
not gonna be a fanatic like I am about
the game so I wanted to get a good
experience there's fireworks after the
game I think kids are running the bases
and I didn't want it to be stressful so
buying tickets to your favorite event
shouldn't be and it doesn't have to be
game time is the fast and easy way to
buy tickets for all the sports music
comedy and theater near you they have
killer deals last minute tickets and
their best price guarantee you can stop
stressing over the tickets and start
getting excited about that fun you're
gonna have forget planning months in
advance game time has deals on tickets
right up to the day of the event you can
get exclusive Flash Deals on tickets for
football basketball baseball concerts
comedy theater and more plus the game
time guarantee means you'll always get
the best price so if you find tickets in
the same section in row for Less game
time is going to credit you 100 110
percent of the difference it's the
fastest growing ticket app in the
country for a reason you get images of
your seat before you buy it so you know
exactly what to expect when you arrive
you buy tickets in a matter of seconds
two Taps and you're set tickets are sent
directly to your phone so you never have
to dig through your email and I'm gonna
tell you I went right through the app it
was simple I've had friends from home go
what's that app you're talking about I'm
like game time go check it out I'm
taking Stella to see the game so stack
the tickets without the stress with Game
Time download the game time app create
an account use code honeydew for twenty
dollars off your first purchase terms
apply again create an account and redeem
code honeydew for twenty dollars off
download game time today last minute
tickets lowest price guaranteed now
let's get back to the dude and um and
the school like I can for look I can
forgive all of these people like I can
forgive them to get them out of my life
but it's disgusting the school should
not be running
um I found so many more things out so
what I did find out in recent years was
I get it I get hit up by this kid who's
like oh did you ever know that okay so
the year after
all this went down when I graduated the
graduation ceremonies were like really
small graduation ceremonies and all
these old students would come back to go
to them because it's 17 kids it's like
this short thing it's like come to
support the school or whatever and
um so after it all happened when I was
still blaming myself for it I really
felt like it was my fault it happened
and if it wasn't my fault it was his
fault but it wasn't I didn't understand
like the institutional issues and what
was going on in school
so I um I went back and it was almost
like a Stockholm syndrome thing too like
I still wanted them to like me and think
I was good because it was such a like
horrific experience after I came out
about all this I mean it was like
horrific and um were you welcomed back
or were they like uh
I mean they were like oh here she is or
whatever but I went in to say hi to that
other art teacher the other one okay
yeah and because he had gotten fired the
teacher that assaulted me got three
years probation and he like wasn't
allowed to teach for a little while it
was like that it was like not yeah
exactly my there was some sort of plea
bargain what happened was his therap or
his therapist his lawyer was uh my old
softball coach I used to play softball
with his daughter and yeah
exactly that's what I think but he lied
to my parents he said I think I can help
Annie by being on the side but he got
his guy off is what he did I can't
believe he just said he got his guy he
got his guy off
I can't believe he said he got his gun I
don't hate lawyers but there's one I
don't like a lot
there's one I don't like a lot Jules I'm
just saying the first name hey Jules get
your ass back home how's your daughter
I'm actually I really like his ex-wife
his ex-wife is like he's a scumbag I'm
like I know man no wonder you feel the
world's against us
it goes all the way back to yourself
funny Ryan I like I was in a
relationship
um maybe like four or five years ago
with someone who also was very like had
a lot of trauma and stuff and he did
like help me through it a lot but it was
a very very intense
toxic is like overused it was just
really a raw relationship where I he
helped me realize like it wasn't my
fault and then that there was no adults
around and it caused some problems with
my family and and stuff like that and I
love my family because they they sat
with me through it the whole time there
was never
a time where they wouldn't talk to me
about it or you know shot me down even
when I was screaming on vacation or
whatever you know because I just
couldn't believe it and I went on Mark
maron's podcast and I told the story and
I was so raw and so emotional I just
remember feeling like
where were all of the grown-ups and I
think what I learned Not Looking Back is
like one of the biggest lies you're told
when you're a kid is like to tell the
truth because a lot of people don't want
the truth they want what's going to be
the easiest thing to move forward and
it's like because I always tell the
truth and I can't tell you how many
times I mean I have people now in this
business that won't speak to me over
things that are like that I am like I
literally just said a thing about
my own life and it's like that if that's
a thing
it just goes like oh you're not like who
I thought you were like you aren't
someone that likes the truth you aren't
someone and and it's also like
I don't know it's just like it's a lot
of things are sticky I think in this
business too it's like
but I don't know I just always like to
just
be expressed well you're also in a happy
relationship now so let me ask you this
like just moving through life meeting
men in position of power or dating or
intimately like how how has all of that
like what filter do you look through for
things like that like do you have do you
feel like you have a sixth sense for
like that person's not a good person or
that you know what I mean I know all the
way over correct and maybe
um I think like this I think I
when something I have a radar now when
something happens I don't like
I'm not okay with it
but I don't
like I the way I handle things is
usually I humiliate them
for a little while yeah and I make sure
I get what I need like I make sure I'm
not gonna yeah I've done some simulation
like where people
I don't mean for Kink I mean have has
anyone
ever come up to you in an appropriate
way where you've done that like just you
know
things that happened to me that come out
about Comics so many people like they
would be bound to me for life like they
would be basically working for me
now my servant you're gonna get me
especially you're gonna get me a TV show
like yeah yeah I had a guy I was working
on a show
and uh it was really it's such an
awesome job it was so cool and I was
Consulting so I would come in just like
here and there and um and so it was
always I always wanted to be asked back
and um the producer tried to make out
with me not once which listen I'll give
you one time like power whatever like
we're funny we're in a room together I I
you know like I'm not gonna be mad at
someone for having a crush on me you
know
um this is a flirty business jokes are
in a in another job might seem like
flirting do you know what I mean like
there could be mixed signals and stuff
so you can shoot your shot once if I say
no And when I say no I do this
I'm very like
um and you lean back in now we have a
problem
so I had one guy do that to me and um
twice and I just when am I coming back
in the room like it's just immediate
like I'm not leaving I'm not gonna leave
this situation so you can feel more
comfortable I'm gonna sit here after I
rejected you twice I'm gonna stay till
the end of the party and I'm gonna get
confirmation from you when I'm back in
the room because you're not gonna like
you're not gonna do something to me and
then affect my career that's not gonna
happen I'm not going to allow that
so then
um I also have had situations where I've
had I've had those smoke sessions you
talk about Outback of the comedy Story
You've just simply said Ryan
I could ruin them all I could and it's
like that's the thing it's like when I
get accused of being one of those women
I'm like if I was coming out with things
like you guys would be in jail like I
don't know what to say it's not like and
not that I'm like oh I have all these
like secrets and I'm keeping them or
whatever but it's like I just
I think that like there's just no way
I'm allowing
what you do to me to affect my freedom
in my business so
um I also had a deal with a network
um I did a showcase for this network and
they were like we want to do this this
like basically develop a sitcom with me
so the guy who's running it is this
married guy I I just in my head when I
first moved to Hollywood I thought the
casting couch all that stuff I thought
it was completely made up
I in my head I was like oh that's like a
funny tale that people tell I thought
married men loved their wives I thought
married men are safe like it just didn't
even [__] occur to me it was just
like complete naivety and so I had a
situation where the guy was like oh I'm
like oh I'm running late to this meeting
why don't we just meet up later at the
Soho House
and I was like oh cool the Soho house
that's awesome I'm like new to Hollywood
I'm like that's so fun you know go to
this like membership place
so we go and he starts going you know
what I really like about your comedy is
how um openly like promiscuous you are
and I was like that's not what my comedy
is I was like that's not at all what my
comedy is I was like I'm not that's not
at all
what my stand-up is about or whatever
and he goes and he starts touching my
knee and I just start to be like what is
happening here right so I go let me see
a picture of your wife
show me your kids he's like show me his
kids I'm thinking it's like okay you see
it we like he's like let me give you a
tour he like pulls me in he he's giving
me a tour of like the Billiards him he
like goes to pull me in he goes oh you
have such a nice ass or something and I
go
I go I'm funny I work really hard I'm
very confident in myself absolutely not
and then we like go down we leave and
he's like I hope you don't tell anyone
about this he said that yeah and I was
like whatever and then he goes and then
he goes whatever happens in Montreal
this summer stays in Montreal I go it's
not gonna happen
and then the next day
where let's talk about the sitcom to the
next day
we doing the sitcom and I ended up I
never made a sitcom but I did get paid
for it good that thing because I was
like not a [__] chance you're not
[__] with me I work hard I don't
there's no like and it's funny because
I'll talk to people in the business
level but even if you did hook up with
them I'm like but I didn't I didn't I
never did I've never hooked up with
anyone to get anything those are like
I've had rumors spread that I like
hooked up with a guy to get into
Montreal like crazy things where I'm
like
it's so far from them so I think if
anything that's what like the experience
in high school give me where I was like
I'm never ever like allowing a person in
that position to ever make me feel
vulnerable like that and uh so
professionally that's one how about
personally how do you deal in your
personal life when through dating how's
that been for you well I think I someone
told me that I always date my mom my dad
my mom my dad one of my friends my God
so I'll date like a girly guy who's kind
of like aloof and like is too busy for
me and then a guy that's like really
[__] mean to me but very funny and
and sweet too you know but so mean like
my dad and then it would go back and
forth and back and forth
um but I healed myself and now I have
like a good like a secure man who's it
doesn't I was so like coded I was always
trying to make people like me like even
when I went back to my high school this
I didn't finish the story when I went
would go back to visit trying to like
I'm like I wanted these people to like
me they did me dirty and I wanted them I
I felt like I was like well do you not
like me I didn't do anything you know
and I was just like begging them and it
just
so I go in for the graduation and I go
to my the art teacher I pop in he's with
the graduates uh and I pop and I go like
hey and he goes this room's only for
current graduates get the [__] out whoa
and I'm like
what like I'm like I'm like in the
hallway like about to cry I'm like why
am I getting like abused by these people
by the way my teacher that assaulted me
was very mean to me he wasn't flattering
he wasn't nice there was nothing he was
very mean to me the whole time even did
you have to work uh work with him after
my mom kept trying to get me to go back
over to the house I was like I don't
want to go to the house anymore I go Dad
come pick me up I never want to go back
to this house I didn't tell them what
happened yet
I didn't tell them until I had to until
we were like going to the cops
but um and then my best friend that girl
ended up telling the cops I was lying
and that was a pathological liar and I
am autistically honest I have always
told the truth I do not lie I am like
ass burgers honest that I went to
occupational therapy Ryan I'm on the
Spectrum I tell the truth I do not lie
I'm not comfortable lying it's like
so that used to be a really big trigger
when people come in and it's still kind
of like
it affects me a little bit still when
people don't believe me but it should I
mean you've got a whole you had an Army
against you right you had to school
again she had the students against you
you had your parents unsure or you had
the wife but you know what the part I
had to to fix was that I was against me
that's the only one that matters there's
no other relationship that matters in
this world other than your relationship
with yourself and so I had to do so much
work on self-love and like literally I
would do like the gayest [__] sorry I'm
saying gay but it's just the right word
I would have to do the gayest [__] like
right like look in the mirror for like I
would do anything I'd be like I love
myself I love myself I love you I love
you I love you and you like you have to
like lie to yourself until you believe
it and now I catch myself with any
negative thoughts like I do not go there
anymore and I feel like
you know very Unstoppable at this point
in my life and it's like you know I look
back and then I have to forgive myself
for being at the phase in my life where
I didn't trust myself and I didn't like
myself but I always work on self trust
whenever I'm upset or triggered there's
a self-trust issue
um
and uh but anyway so I find okay so I
get yelled up at the the yeah this is
the one that was okay right didn't know
if you were he wasn't there this [__]
though
the janitor walks by this guy Frank he
goes he saw it and he goes he's like the
only person that I felt like saw me he
goes he used to call me Blondie which is
also sounds molesting but he's the only
one that didn't molest me but he was
like only well I'm sorry he goes I know
but he's still like I was actually
thinking about him recently because he
used to which is also inappropriate but
we used to do community service on
Wednesdays and to get us ready for our
future
so Wednesday's the last half of the day
you picked a community service one was
like you would cook food with the the
chef downstairs
um for homeless people one was like you
would build quilts for you would so
quilts one was like collecting cardboard
boxes and one was Frank's helpers where
you would help him clean them but he was
like
I cleaned the place so he would let us
just be in his office and smoke
cigarettes his office was like in the
basement sounds like he's molesting us
yeah he but he wasn't but in the
basement and he would just pop the thing
up we'd smoke cigarettes and watch Jerry
Springer when Jerry Springer died I was
like where's Frank but um so Frank saw
me after he yelled at me and I stepped
out of the room and he went Blondie he
goes I saw how they treated you in the
school the school did you dirty he's
like I want you and I know that so that
is like and sometimes like do I imagine
him like did I make him up but um so
that was really the only person that
kind of was like even though my parents
were like on my side I hear you though
they my parents up until four years ago
we're donating money to the school no
yeah because they don't want to admit
for them to admit they they sent me
there they tried to get me going back to
that guy's house I understand this this
is them not like for them to fully do
you know how painful that would be for
them
so it's like they had to kind of keep
this distance and stuff and
I think it would be different knowing
what they know now obviously but what I
did learn from my mom
and I have more to get back to about
that relationship between the teacher
who yelled at me on the other one
um my mom went to a boarding school an
all-girls boarding school
when I was going through when I was
dating that guy and I was raw and I was
calling her and like what the [__] did
you do like why where were you all this
stuff why would you like send me to this
guy's house
my mom goes everyone slept over their
teachers houses when they were in high
school everyone that's just how it is
and I go that's not how it is
so then a load time goes by and she goes
oh my God the weirdest thing happened
she goes I just found out that all these
girls in heist in my high school who
used to be the cool girls that would go
hang out and sleep over at this one
teacher's house he molested all of them
so my mom was looking at it like she got
left out from this cool club and up
until three months after I had that
conversation with her she thought it was
normal that kids go sleep at their
teacher's house
and you'd be one of the coolers and that
cheating and so she's like I don't want
to keep her from this cool thing it's
it's all like she just was naive my mom
was not molested and she doesn't she it
didn't occur to her that that would be
what she was left out from it and not
knowing what was on the other side
feeling like
oh it would have been so cool if I got
to hang out with like the grown-ups and
all the cool kids so then that kind of
came full circle and I started to
understand that and I just don't care
it's like I just my parents like do a
lot of work on themselves I talk to them
every day we love each other my mom and
I meditate together it's like it's over
that's all over and so you know and it's
just to me it's like
my parents are old it's like I don't
know I'll miss them so much when they're
gone it's like I don't want any of my
time with them to be like
harboring you know so I just like and
that's kind of I think why I didn't want
to post this before because it was just
like
I wasn't as like secure in that
relationship with them quite yet and I
just didn't I don't want to like
I can like drag them through the mud for
the rest of their lives if I want but
why would I do that I love them you know
and that's really the only thing that's
I'll take with me from this earth when I
die is the love I have for everyone so
and that's what I learned from Ayahuasca
check it out
and this is like not trauma too this is
like you know are you an only child no I
have a twin brother and older brother
that's right you have a twin yeah twins
yeah oh you're a twin too yeah I'm a
fraternal oh fun with a boy yeah weird
um different you said you had more to
say about the two teachers so I find out
okay so this is what I found out from
the school so at this point there's just
one bad teacher and a bunch of teachers
the [__] teacher right an [__]
teacher and people that are like
not wanting to deal with me and like oh
she's causing a problem for us right it
doesn't make sense I'm like why are they
not just on myself but I'm like why are
they not like on my side why were there
no teachers coming to court with me like
why were there no
um and I got a text from one of the old
teachers when I was living in Brooklyn
like 2015 2016.
that was like hey Annie It's so-and-so
from the so-and-so school and um
me and a bunch of the teachers and some
of the students are coming to have like
a little impromptu reunion in Brooklyn I
don't know how they got my number my mom
probably [__] gave it to them
they're like we'd love to see you there
and I go hey
um
uh where were you when I was in court
when I was assaulted by one of your
colleagues no one was with me no one
came to me so
um with all due respect I will be
missing this get-together and then 24
hours later after lawyers had been
contacted I'm sure a very professional
thing was sent back that was like oh the
school is different now
um I was new there that year I didn't
feel comfortable
stepping in like just all this [__]
like I know myself as an adult like
that would never fly
no you you're not doing [__] to anyone
ever in front of me that's not gonna
happen you know but anyway so
it's just a bunch of stuff like that but
you know I had to like over time really
like learn
that this was not my fault this is the
thing that did to me and then on top of
that I had to learn that it's not a part
of me it's just a thing that went
through me and happened to me so anyway
so
I got um a DM from one of my old
classmates and he goes oh you're not
gonna believe what happened this teacher
the older art teacher
um he goes the year after he left after
you graduated he found out one of the
teachers was having an Affairs on the
students and he went and he punched him
and then that guy ran off and never came
back again and I'm like why are you
telling me like this is a good story so
there was another teacher [__] a
student in a class in a school with with
each grade has 17 kids in it okay so
everyone's [__] everyone basically
yeah and I'm going and then by the way
he punched him he didn't call the cops
get him arrested have any legal
repercussions he just got to run off to
another school to go do it again
there's no newspaper article like where
was my newspaper article
like they [__] manipulated my parents
into not doing that that's what year was
this it was like 1995 or 1996. so
there's no internet or anything like
that to blast them it's just starting
right at the time
and it's like but you know but I'm like
in court I'm like I just never no none
of them have ever reached out or I mean
they've got to be teaching themselves
like that's one of my no I know they
must be scared yeah everybody like ideas
of things I want to do like to really
get the story out
yeah good ideas but I don't know if I
want to do it it's like it really is up
to me to figure out like what do I what
is like
also do you put any more [__] energy
exactly exactly because you're you're
your body is remembering it the whole
time you're working on some [__] like
that you know what I mean exactly and
I'm talking to the people and right but
my uh
so I find that out so there's another
teacher and this was a teacher that was
new that year but why would a teacher
come into this environment and think
it's an appropriate environment to have
a relationship with that kid because you
guys are [__] creeps
knowing there was a scandal there before
oh and it's still okay because was there
a scandal if if the TR if the kid gets
jerked off on in the in the woods and no
one's in there to hear it did the kid
get jerked off on in the woods
there's no [__] newspaper article
about it did she get jerked off into the
woods so anyway so
so they [__] okay so then I mean this
story just goes crazy so then okay so
then I find out
I get a DM from one of the old teachers
oh God it just keeps going yes one of
the old teachers
and I like this [__] teacher I'll
tell you this this teacher he was my
math teacher a different math teacher he
goes hey he comes out of nowhere he goes
hey I listen to Mark Maron he goes I'm
disgusted he's like I didn't know
exactly I knew shady [__] was going on
he's like I'm so sorry I didn't find out
exactly what was happening because I
would have gone to court with you I
would have fought for you because those
people are scumbags and he's like and I
want to let you know that when that guy
was when the teacher that assaulted you
was a student he was having an affair
with the other art teacher a gay Affair
no he was a molester he was a molester
he was a molester they were a molester
holy that guy was a molester that guy
was a mustard that girl's a [__]
[__] white people with dreads I'm so
sorry [__] you guys
[__] my people with dreads or don't [__]
them
I'm sorry I don't mean to discriminate
against you but are you [__] kidding
me so then um okay so she was having an
affair and now they're command
everyone's [__] everyone Jesus okay
I've got more so so when that guy
knocked the teacher out he was knocking
him out like you're gonna out all of us
by the way after the Marc Maron thing I
see what are you doing dumb [__]
we're all gonna get in trouble after the
Marc Maron thing the school used to be
um it used to be a Montessori school
before it became the school that I went
to I just say I'm a less story School
that's in the notebooks just vaginas
just that we we read the vaginas of the
students we just read them like we do a
little a dog here while we slip our
[__] in there but anyway so okay so yes
this continues which is wow
I mean it just it's like never ending
teacher punches the guy because you're
gonna get us in trouble I got a DM after
my Marc Maron from a woman who went to
the Montessori School in the 70s she
goes oh the teachers were doing this to
us too I mean it's like decades decades
and I go we got to take them down and
she goes what do you mean it was a long
time ago and I was like what do you mean
it was a long time lady let's [__] go
come on [__] so then uh it's kind to
say is it is it just girls or is it boys
well he was a boy the teacher was a boy
right I think it's no it's all them
because I have another one okay okay so
then I had an enemy in high school this
guy okay he was this inner city black
kid wait real quick so the lady from the
70s was like nah people they whatever
and who cares
[__] I don't need you I got bing bing
bing bing I got it I gotta stack don't
worry
so okay so
there was a guy in high school who a
second fights with he was an inner city
kid he was getting out of gangs he
started going to the school and he was
like a talented guy was a good poet very
like well spoken like smart just like a
cool kid but we fought because I don't
have like Authority with people like I
don't like I didn't know like where in
the streets he was from I just talked to
people
the same way or whatever so we were
getting I was like flicking boogers at
him and stuff and he's like I actually
kind of respected you because nobody
like treated me like that because they
like knew what I was you know what I
could do to them but they were like
holding him back I was like what are you
gonna hit me like Bing Bing Bing like we
were just always getting in fights man
this guy
we ended up like reuniting later on and
I love him okay this is like my [__] has
he come to see you do stand up and stuff
yes he has seen me do stand up and our
friend who passed away too came one of
our he was he was one that that
um succeeded to adversible but but he is
a really talented author and he wrote a
book when we when we reconnected he had
written a book about the school in a
positive light how this school he had
gone to the school of like a bunch of
like combine looking white kids and but
how it really helped him like reform his
life and turn himself around
and now he's a professor a rapper like
he's just so [__]
he's amazing I don't want to say his
name because this is like his story but
um
he uh so he had this positive experience
and I'm like do you remember what
happened with me and he goes I don't
really like I vaguely know something
happened and I told him he was like I
wish you had I had known that before I
wrote this like glowing book about it
was like a national like a New York
Times bestseller whoa the book okay and
um
I think New York Times or some it was a
bestseller but so
I'm telling him the story and stuff and
he's like he's like well I like support
you in any of this and he's just like
he's just my guy he's my one of my
people for life I love him so much like
such like a family situation we've just
been through this this place together
and had such opposite experiences isn't
it wild that in such a small little
space two people could have
wildly different experiences but wait oh
no so I got a call
a couple years ago from him
my sister-in-law's house he goes I don't
know who else to tell this to
he goes I called my mom he saw the movie
moonlight
you know which is about a a gay
relationship or something causes mom
and he goes mom you know like wow I
really like felt for this character I
you know I've never had like any
homosexual like relationships or
anything like that
but
you know I could really like empathize
with this character and her mom's like
you don't remember what happened in high
school
he had a mentor okay
this teacher he had a mentor who he was
like the acting teacher
and I think maybe he did a writing too
you
like
helped him
but his mom was like you don't remember
what happened I found he was writing him
love letters and he didn't understand
there were love letters because we're
like kids you don't like get it
his mom found them in his thing and was
like this guy's writing Love Letters to
my son so she goes to the principal oh
the teacher was running into him oh [__]
she goes to the principal
um they meet with the teacher the
teacher goes yes I'm in love with your
son they go okay you need to move out of
here so he moves to another state never
cops never anything so he's doing it
over there right so then he just moved
he died of coven sorry rep
um sorry you're not gonna be able to see
what happens in the end but
[Music]
um
uh so my friend I felt so bad for
because he then was questioning like
this was someone that really motivated
him to have a good life too and now he's
to look back and he's like what's he
using me I'm like that's the thing
that's [__] up it's like
it's this like special kid thing
you know but my teacher was mean to me
so I don't even get that sorry but um
but he uh
yeah it's just so it's wild so then he
had had that too and then the principal
I believe at some point ran off with one
of the students Jesus Christ is still
open exactly
exactly how but I think like what
happens is like one of those funded like
I don't know I don't know but one of the
like spins that I would go through when
I was in a more anxious place would be
like are they gonna like like sue me and
like it's still like it does feel like
there's like a
like a church against me you know it
does feel like that it feels when
there's an institution that's like
United against you and they're powerful
as [__] right yeah but I don't know they
literally have boxes right literally but
I think my I think I'm more powerful
than them now and I think it's just
about what I'm interested in doing
and I don't want like and then I do
these things and I'm like oh I don't
want them to be tipped off either
yeah I look I there's a situation I'm
sort of going through where there's a
chance to do a or a chance to do B
that's all I'm gonna say I'll tell you
after it's nothing but but
does a involve
you know the better part of my time
because if it does then I'm not
interested at all like because I have to
live it I've got to you know be present
in it I've got to relive it I've gotta
live it I gotta think about all these
people and this and then again people
are telling me they're lie I'm a liar
and they don't believe me like you had
you had your own [__] softball
coaches going against you like that
shit's crazy no wonder you feel like
it's me against the world you should but
I work on that and I and it's like
because I do believe like you'll
recreate all of these things over and
over again until you break the cycle of
it and it's like so it's just about not
letting myself get into that mindset and
then you just cut people cut them out
yeah that's the thing too as you get
older you gotta
if they're not bringing something to the
table we gotta cut that down I mean when
I saw
um the Banshees of
whatever the hell that movie is you've
seen it you didn't see it with Colin
Farrell in the the Irish movie oh no I
haven't yet it's basically Colin Farrell
gets like friend dumped by this guy and
they just like live in this like small
area in Ireland there's no one else to
hang out with and stuff and he's like
keeps trying to hang out with him he
goes you're so boring like
that I would rather like cut he was a
fiddler or he played some sort of
instrument he's like I will cut my
fiddle fingers off if you come near me
again that's how much you're like like
ruining the rest of my life kind of I
want to send that to so many people that
are like so bored I'm like I can't
handle boring people I can't handle
people that are like manipulating and
toxic it's like I am like here to rise
and be in the light and have fun and
laugh that's it I don't have time for
any of that other stuff so I mean though
I have something that could be pretty
cool I could do it's also like do I want
to do it
but
it doesn't matter either way whatever I
choose now I mean you're killing it and
I feel great and I feel very like not
detached from it but I feel like not
like I do feel like it's like a separate
thing all right so let me ask you this
because of question I ask technically
this is your first time so and this is a
pivotal moment too what advice would you
give your 16 year old self duck
duck from the spray
[Laughter]
oh man well thank you very much for
coming on this has been a great episode
thanks man it'll never hear will you uh
please plug and promote everything one
more time yes okay I'll get my actual
turns out can I ask you why you're
looking too your purse is always around
you is it a Philly thing
do you always worry someone's gonna
steal no I have 80d if I take my purse
off it's left I have to drive back and
get it yeah okay I just wondered if it
was a street thing I remember like my
Louis Vuitton and people are like oh my
God we gotta forget your dates you're
right I go first of all yeah I [__]
spend some money on this [__] I don't
want to put it down but I I leave
everything everywhere
oh my God
okay
you're going to Baltimore you said yes I
am sorry
oh I love stand up it's so fun
all right but I also I do want to say
this it's really important to not like
wallow and like live in the [__] you
have to like go through it and
everything but yep sit in it I still get
up and get the [__] out I got like a
crash course in life really young and I
always say I had to be an adult when I
was a kid so I get to be a kid when I'm
an adult and I love my life I change
nothing man I like that because nothing
I changed nothing I'm proud of myself
and I just work every day on continuing
to like be proud of myself make myself
proud all that stuff good for you and I
just forgive as many people as I can
okay I have Baltimore magoobies June 2nd
and 3rd I'll be in Salt Lake City Utah
on Wise Guys with Josh Potter June 9th
and 10th I'll be in San Antonio Texas
June 23rd and 24th I'm in Philadelphia
August 11th and 12th I'm in Calgary at
The Great Outdoors Comedy Festival with
Andrew Schultz August 27th and I'm in
Austin Texas at the Vulcan gas company
October 6th and 7th I also have like San
Francisco San Jose a bunch of other
stuff on the on the
calendars you go to Annie lairman.com
shows also every Tuesday's trash Tuesday
and a lot of people already watched that
so come to my new show anniewood I need
more of you over there it's so cute it's
so fun
um it's just my world it's anniewood
California it's all the people that I
love all of my friends people I'm fans
of we have like my favorite reality
stars on we have my favorite authors my
favorite everyone it's always a good
time so that's every Thursday that's it
comes out at 9 00 a.m PST 12 p.m Eastern
and I do a live chat on there when I'm
available so you can come talk to me and
hang out all right thank you very much
hell yeah oh and June 20th Annie and
friends at The Comedy Store
got Sickler's on it oh if I'm here
um thank you as always go support the
special come see me on tour tickets at
ryancicler.com we'll talk to you all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]